introducing Apple Vision Pro Vision Pro
Vision Pro Vision Pro Vision Pro yes
Apple's mixed reality headset is now a
reality here at the company's Cupertino
campus it just showed off the
long-awaited reality headset the face
computer my term not theirs Bridges
virtual reality where you're fully
transported to a virtual world with
augmented reality where you see virtual
objects in your real world Apple's
calling it spatial Computing and yes it
starts at 34.99 Apple spent 45 minutes
detailing how it works and what you can
do with it let me break it down for you
in way less time these are three dollar
lab goggles that's it looks like a pair
of aluminum and glass ski goggles
basically these but cooler and way more
expensive the front of the device has a
screen so people can see your eyes when
you're wearing it creepy kinda it looks
way Slimmer and lighter than meta's
Quest Pro one of the big reasons for
that a cord from the headset attaches to
this battery pack Apple says the battery
will last two hours you can also plug it
into an outlet to use it all day
on the one hand I'm excited not to wear
a battery on my head on the other hand
battery fanny packs there are no
controllers like other VR headsets you
use your hands to navigate around there
are multiple cameras on the device too
which help you see the real world with
digital objects in it the Apple watch
like digital Crown dial lets you get to
the home screen and also controls how
much of the virtual world you see you
can even use the cameras to capture
spatial 3D videos and photos it's easy
to capture a spatial photo or video with
just the Press of a button if you're
wondering how you log in Iris scans with
optic ID Apple says your iscans are kept
on the device
so what do you do once you've got that
on your head and all that other stuff on
your body well Apple shut off a few
experiences
surprisingly a lot of the things shown
have to do with work you can see
multiple windows from your Mac above
your desk Microsoft apps like Excel word
and teams make full use of the expansive
canvas and sharp text rendering of
Vision Pro you can FaceTime with family
or colleagues the FaceTime stuff is
pretty crazy since you're not holding a
camera out in front of your face you
create a scan instead basically a
hologram to appear in your chats there's
stuff to do in your downtime too like
watching immersive 3D movies and playing
Apple arcade games there's game
controller support too
but what Apple's really hoping is that
software developers build new
applications for vision OS the operating
system powering it all Disney CEO Bob
Iger even showed off some virtual Disney
experiences this platform will allow us
to bring Disney to our fans in ways that
were previously impossible I have a lot
of thoughts on it all I should be should
be trying it out soon stay tuned for my
first impressions
foreign